PROFESSOR: We began
our introduction
to molecules last
time and tried to get
a picture of the scales
that are involved.
In these objects we spoke of
a lattice of nuclei and clouds
of electrons in which a
molecule had some scale,
A. Then we had electronic
energies E, electronic.
We had vibrational energies.
This is from the nuclei.
And we had rotational energies.
And they were one
bigger than the other
and bigger than the last.
In fact, the electronic
energies were
bigger than the vibrational
energies of the nuclei
and bigger than the rotational
energies of the whole molecule
when it rotates as a solid body.
In fact, the ratio was like 1 to
square root of little m over M,
where little m represents
electron mass, and capital M,
the nuclear mass.
And so this number could
be 10 to the minus 2,
and then you have m over M.
So that's the proportions.
So this is larger than
the second one, like 1
is larger than that, and
the ratio between these two
is this.
So that's what we've discussed.
And we said that,
in some sense, there
was an adiabatic approximation
in the vibration of the nuclei.
As the nuclei vibrate, they pull
the electronic clouds with it
in an adiabatic way.
That is, if you solved
for the electronic cloud
as a function of
position, that would
be a family of eigenstates.
Say the ground state
of the electronic cloud
is a function of position, this
would be a family of states.
If the positions of the
nuclei change in time,
you could use those as
instantaneous eigenstates.
And there is a sense in which
this is a good approximation,
given that the
timescale associated
to the vibrations
of the nuclei is
much bigger than the
timescale associated
to any variation in the
electronic configuration.
This is just because of
the scales of the energies.
So let's implement this idea
in an approximation that
is used to solve molecules.
And we'll discuss
it in all detail.
I'll skip one step
of the derivation.
One calculation will
be in the notes,
but I don't want to go
through the details in class.
And we will appreciate the form
of the nuclear Hamiltonian, how
it behaves.
So this is going to be the
Born-Oppenheimer approximation.
And we will consider
the situation
where we have N, nuclei--
capital N, nuclei-- and
little m, electrons.
So it's a many-body wavefunction
and a many-body situation.
In such cases, your
notation is important.
You have to define
labels that help
you distinguish this situation.
So here are the
labels we're going
to use for the nuclei, P
alpha and R alpha, where alpha
denotes which nuclei
you're talking about.
So it goes from 1
up to capital N,
because there are
capital N nuclei
for each nucleus, the first,
the second, the third.
There is a momentum operator
and a position operator,
each one of which is three
components, because molecules
live in three dimensions.
So this is one vector
and another vector
for each value of alpha.
In fact, these are operators.
We're doing quantum
mechanics, so these
are our canonical
pairs for the nuclei,
canonical pairs for the nuclei.
We need similar variables
for the electrons,
and we'll use little
p and little r,
both vectors, both operators.
And this time this i runs
from 1 to lower case n.
And these are the canonical
pairs for the electrons.
So when we write
the Hamiltonian,
it should be a Hamiltonian that
depends on all those variables.
And we can write
the Hamiltonian,
because we know the
physics of this situation.
We think of this is
a lattice of nuclei,
and there is the cloud
of the electrons,
and we have a coordinate system.
Here is maybe capital
R1 and capital R2.
They're all there.
And well, when we
write Hamiltonian,
we think of the electrons at
some points and write things.
So let's write the Hamiltonian.
So this is going to be
the total Hamiltonian.
What should I include?
I should include kinetic
terms for each of the nuclei.
So I should put sum over alpha.
I don't have to repeat
here from 1 to capital N.
You know already
what alpha runs over.
P alpha vector
squared over 2M alpha.
M alpha is the mass
of alpha nucleus.
It could be a collection
of protons and neutrons.
Then there's going to be--
and we get a little more
schematic-- a potential that
depends nucleus with nucleus.
So the nucleus,
among each other,
have a Coulomb potential.
So there's going to be a
potential that represents here,
and it will depend
on the various R's.
I could write--
this looks funny.
You say, which R?
Well, it depends on
all the capital R's.
So I could write
depends on this set
that, but it's a
little too cumbersome.
I'll just write V
of R, like this.
And this is, if the nuclei
lived alone, that would be it.
This would be the kinetic
energies and the potential
between the nuclei.
Then there's going to be what
we can call a Hamiltonian that
only involves the electrons.
In some sense, that gives
dynamics to the electrons--
not only involves
electrons, gives
dynamics to the electrons.
And this Hamiltonian, H
e, is going to depend on--
well, this big Hamiltonian
for all the molecules
depends on the two
canonical pairs
for times N times little n.
This Hamiltonian for
the electron will depend
on the p's, will depend on the
r's, and it will also depend
on the capital R's.
And you can think of it,
and that's reasonable.
Suppose you're an electron.
Who affects you?
Well, you get affected
by your electron friends,
and you get affected
by the nuclei
and therefore, by the positions
of the nuclei, as well.
So this is the electron
part of the Hamiltonian.
And it would be given by a sum
of kinetic energy, as usual.
So i, sum over i this time,
little p, i squared over 2m.
Let's assume, of course, all
the electrons are the same mass.
And then we would have, just
in this shorthand, a potential
that represents the
interaction of the electrons
with the nuclei.
And that potential would
depend on the R's, on the R's.
And finally-- my picture maybe
should be moved the little
to the right--
there's a term, the electron
potential that just depends
on the R's.
So all these potentials
are Coulomb potentials,
Coulomb from nucleus-nucleus,
nucleus-electron,
electron-electron.
So here it is.
You've written the Hamiltonian.
And if you have three
nuclei and five electrons,
you could write
all the equations.
And it's a nice thing that
you can write the Hamiltonian,
and you could dream of
putting it into a computer,
and it will tell you
what the molecule is,
and that's roughly true.
But even for a good computer
nowadays, this is difficult.
So you have to try to think how
you can simplify this problem.
So one way to think about
it is to think again
of the physics of the situation.
We'll have a
separation of scales.
It's lucky we have that
separation of scales,
very light electrons,
very heavy nuclei.
So let's think of a
fixed nuclear skeleton,
and consider electron
states associated
to that fixed nuclear skeleton.
The nuclear skeleton
is not fixed.
In principle, the nuclei
are not classical particles
with fixed positions.
They're going to vibrate.
But we're trying to
understand this problem,
and to some approximation,
we can roughly
think of them localized.
So let's exploit that
and use the vibrations.
So for large M alpha, this
[INAUDIBLE] to large M
alpha, consider a
fixed nuclear skeleton.
So that means fixed R alpha,
all the R alphas, and fix.
And now calculate
the electron states
as a function of our alpha.
So you simplify the problem.
Ignore all this
dynamics of the nuclei,
all this nuclear-nuclear
interaction.
Focus on the electrons
as if the nuclear
are completely fixed, and try
to figure out the dynamics.
So there are going to be
many electronic states.
This is electrons in
some fixed potential.
Any particle in quantum
mechanics in a fixed potential.
There are many
energy eigenstates.
So these electrons are going to
have many energy eigenstates.
So let's try to decide on a
name for this wavefunction.
So I will call them
phi for electrons.
If there are wavefunctions
that are wavefunctions
of the electrons,
naturally, they just
depend on the electron
positions, nothing else.
A wavefunction for a particle
depends on the position.
Now, this r hides a little of--
thing.
This really means that
phi of r1, r2, r3, r4,
because they're
little n electrons,
so it's not just one variable.
So I can say this is r1,
r2, all of them, r little n.
That's a wavefunction.
Now, we said there are
many of those states.
So there will be the
ground state, the next one,
the next one, the next one.
So we should put an i in this.
Maybe an i in this
is the wrong letter,
given that they have i there--
k in this.
But there is more
dependence here.
There is implicit dependence on
the positions of the lattice,
because these wave
functions depend
on what lattice square
did you place the nuclei.
At this moment, you're
placing them arbitrarily.
So this means that this
wavefunction really
depends, of course, of how
did you build the lattice?
Did you build the
lattice this way,
or did you build it this way?
It makes a difference.
So it depends on the
capital R's, as well,
which is the position
of the lattice.
So here is our wavefunction.
I will simplify the
writing by writing
phi of capital R, little
r, and k here, see.
So what equation do
we demand from this?
Well we have the
electron Hamiltonian.
So that's what we should solve.
We should solve H
electron, on phi R, k of r.
We'll have some energies,
and those energies
will be electronic energies.
That's for electronic energy.
It will depend on k-- those are
the various energies, as well--
and what else?
Certainly the energies
don't depend on r.
That's your eigenstate.
But they can depend
and will depend
on capital R. Capital R
is the parameters that
define your lattice.
Clearly they should
depend on that.
And then you have phi k, R, r.
So this is the equation
you should solve in order
to find electronic states
associated with a skeleton.
And now suppose you wanted
to find a complete solution
of the Schrodinger equation.
You say, ah, approximations.
Why should they
do approximations?
I can solve things exactly,
which is almost never possible,
but we can imagine that.
So what would be a possible way
to write an [? n-set ?] would
be the following.
You could write a psi for the
whole thing now that depends
on the R's.
And the R's wavefunction for
the whole degrees of freedom
of the molecule could be
written as a sum over k
of phi K, R of r times
solutions, eta k, that
depend on capital R.
That is, I'm saying
we can try to write
the solution in which the full
wavefunction for the molecule
is the sum of states of
this form, a solution here
and a solution there.
This is correct, but then how
do you determine the etas?
The only way to
determine the etas
is to plug into the full
Schrodinger equation--
this is the full Hamiltonian.
So you would have to plug
this into the full Schrodinger
equation and see what you get.
So what are you going to get?
Presumably, you did
solve this first part.
So the phis are known.
So if the phis are
known, you're going
to find differential
equations for the etas.
So this problem has become now
a problem of finding solutions
for the etas.
And there are many etas,
and they are all coupled
by the Schrodinger equation.
So by the time you
plug this into H,
the total H, capital
psi Rr equals
sum Eq, sum energy eigenstate--
I don't have to put the thing--
psi Rr, to find the energy
eigenstates of the molecules.
This equation is going to
imply a set of differential
equations, a couple differential
equations for the etas.
And that's not so easy to do.
That's pretty hard in general.
So this is very difficult.
On the other hand,
there is a way
to think of this in
a simpler context.
We can try-- and now
we are approximating--
so try to believe that you can
get an approximate solution,
approximate.
And I will justify
this solution using
just one term in this
equation, and psi phi R of r.
And this may be the ground
state of the electronic system.
That's why I don't
put an index here.
I could put a 0
there, but let's think
of this as the ground state.
And then, well, this
would be accompanied,
if there is some
solution, by sum eta of R.
And I can try to say that
your wavefunction is this,
one term in this equation, the
one in which I pick the ground
state and leave it there.
Now, this is
definitely not going
to be an exact solution ever
of the Schrodinger equation.
So you really are--
if you just take
one of these terms--
out of luck in terms of
solving this exactly,
because this
differential equation,
this Hamiltonian,
has terms mixing
the two degrees of freedom.
It doesn't separate.
You cannot show that the
Schrodinger equation has
a solution which is one thing
that solves an equation and one
thing that solves another
equation that are products like
that.
It will not happen.
That's why in this
equation when you plug in,
the various etas get coupled.
But this is the spirit of
the adiabatic approximation,
in which we sort of
have an electronic cloud
and a nuclear state, and when
the nuclear state changes
slowly, the electronic
cloud adjusts,
and you don't have
to jump to a state
with another electronic cloud.
The electronic cloud adjusts.
So this is in the spirit of
the adiabatic approximation,
to try to find the solution
of this kind, in which
an electronic
cloud is not forced
to jump, because the coupling
between those states,
saying that if you start
with one eta of one phi,
you need all the rest, as the
Schrodinger equation tells you.
It is a statement that the
electronic cloud just cannot
stay by itself where it is.
So here we go.
This is what we're going to try.
And you can say,
well, all right.
So you're giving up the
Schrodinger equation,
because exact Schrodinger
equation is not solved by this.
How are you going to try
to understand now the eta?
Because we found these
guys, so how about the etas?
How are we going to find them?
That is our question.